[Musique]
jacques chirac il
il est sorti de la politique il est
rentré dans l'histoire donc ce serait
normal donc c'est normal qu'il y ait des
places des quais et des rues des
boulevards qui s'appelle jacques chirac
laurent lui doit on lui doit beaucoup
d'unité nationale en a besoin a besoin
de temps en temps de se de se retrouver
dans le souvenir et dans certain nombre
de convictions partagées il fait partie
de ces personnages politiques qui ont
marqué la france comme comme jamais
c'est à dire une connaissance des
territoires des terroirs de france
jacques chirac c'est la france des
sous-préfectures ils connaissent elles
ça sa carte de france par coeur toutes
les personnes qui l'ont croisé vous
diront qu'il avait une vraie vraie
passion pour les gens donc ça c'est sait
quelque chose
enfin c'est une énergie qui a
durablement marqué la vraie question
c'est comment on finance cette cette
baisse d'impôts aujourd'hui on la
finance pas on la finance pas part de la
baisse de la dépense pour au fond on
aubert la vie future des français c'est
cette une
c'est on abdique sur l'idée qu' on
souhaite reconquérir notre souveraineté
financière le j'en ai un peu assez
d'expliquer que nous ne sommes pas
l'extrême droite et que nous ne sommes
pas nous sommes dans l'opposition à
emmanuel macron et le fait de dire je ne
suis pas ça et je ne suis pas ça il ya
un moment où il faut dire se connaît il
faut dire ce que l'on propose je dirais
que une opposition sa s'opposent mais ça
propose aussi est donc venu le temps de
la proposition de crise il faut pas
quitter contraste entre la réalité que
les gens voient et des paroles que les
que l'époque les responsables prononce
vous avez un nuage de fumée énorme et où
vous avez un préfet carrés qui dit
circulez ya rien à voir
y a pas de danger non j'ai fait une
faute voilà b bien sûr qu'une faute de
communication ce dont on a besoin
aujourd'hui c'est d'expliquer très
précisément ce qui s'est passé c'est
quels sont les produits qui ont été
diffusés quelles en sont les
conséquences
des analyses sont en cours évidemment
d'une transparence totale on sent bien
qu effectivement parce qu'il ya une
inquiétude il suffit de regarder les
images télévisées
de voir cette fumée noire comment ne pas
être inquiet comment ne pas avoir de
doutes mais bon les scientifiques sont
là pour apporter ses réponses et ce qui
est important c'est effectivement que la
transparence soit faite dans ces moments
de crise il faudrait que la parole
publique soient stables qu'elles soient
de l'information sont pas là pour être
rassuré les gens sans l'aide pour être
informé
[Musique]